[Music]
[Applause]
speaking of joke Kevin milar Major
League Baseball Network
what he's our buddy
let me try that again uh speaking of a
joke Kevin Millar MLB network analyst he
won a World Series with the Red Sox he's
on intentional talk all post-season long
MLB network errors pre and post game
coverage throughout October how are you
buddy
Danny I'm doing good buddy how you doing
pal I'm doing great I'm doing great uh
where do you want to start
well I'll tell you right now it was
interesting we do our predictions
immediately right so immediately looking
at these predictions uh I'm three out of
four I did pick the Marlins to win over
the Phillies uh you know fighting fish
played for them many years I love what
Schumacher's doing over there I think
they're a sneaky underrated Club but
I'll tell you right now wheeler he could
be the best postseason pitcher we got
going right now he has found his rhythm
on the mound with a power type stuff and
that sweeper and just learning how to
pitch he could be devastating in the
postseason all right help me with this
sweeper craze okay what is a sweeper and
how different is it from a curveball
so let's let's just talk about that I'm
glad you asked because when I played it
was an uppercut now they call it launch
angle right so that's just a it's a
really smart way to act like we're
really educated on all this stuff
sweeper is in between a curveball the
curveball has a little hump the slider
has this downward action and a sweeper
is a little bit in between so we can
call that just that combination of the
curveball slider that now we have the
smart word called the sweeper yeah but
we already had this it was called the
slurve
we had that before that's what you threw
in high school yeah
that's why you got a headset on right
now Danny I remember you we face each
other back in the day I thought I I
would buckle your knees and I and I had
the Kershaw 12-6 uh did you really yeah
and what happened let me guess you got
hurt and then all of a sudden the coach
didn't you know kind of screwed you over
and you ended up having to go into
announcing or what happened no no I
decided to take my talents to basketball
and dominate there
oh by the way I was watching the
documentary on Mike VEC yes and have you
seen the documentary that they did
so I want to watch it with my family I
know exactly about we had back on he's
one of my favorite people in the world
he is exactly everything you want as
Just Energy and treat people with
kindness and love I'll tell you I went
back they retired my jersey a couple
summers ago and 30 years ago in 1993 I
played the Saint Paul Saints as an
undrafted player went up there at the
nor league and staff members are still
there still there from the time I was
there 30 years which tells you what they
treat you amazingly and they're first
class but yes I'm excited to see
remember anything but I want to watch it
with my family yeah it's really well
done Uh Kevin Millar MLB network analyst
give me the team that you think is in
trouble right now
uh the Brewers I I love what you know
Craig council's done up there I think
it's it's been magnificent and he
doesn't get enough credit for what what
he's done uh offensively you know
they've been a team that might be their
little monkey wrench they have enough to
put together uh they're starting
pitching is great but when you lose
Brandon Woodworth I think that's a big
deal you know now you got a lot of
pressure on obviously Corbin Burns and
Peralta so if you were to ask me one
team a little in trouble that would be
them
give me the team that's not in trouble
at all once the Billy Billy's I mean
they are that group right they remind me
of the o4 team the O3 team that I played
for for the Red Sox that team that just
is Scrappy they got a couple Superstars
they got I mean real Muto is my favorite
player I mean he is just a ball player
that kind of keeps that glue together
Castellanos obviously this year settling
down it's hard you sign a big deal we
see it all the time you come in trying
to do too much and then when things
settle down he's the player that they've
all wanted and you've seen what he can
do schwarber it doesn't make sense to a
lot of people but he draws his walks he
has to strikeouts there but he's got 50
home runs in that back pocket and
obviously Bryce Harper is all ball
player and Trey Turner he is getting hot
when he's hot this team's dangerous and
I think they're the team okay help me
understand Kyle schwarber
he does hit home runs he gets on base
he's not a great player he can't run he
strikes out
um but he's extremely valuable I I still
have to believe Kevin putting the ball
in play is far more valuable than
striking out you know 150 to 200 times I
agree and I think he's a much better
hitter than than he than he has been as
far as hitter-wise I mean he was coming
up I remember Theo Epstein loved him in
the Cubs organization uh in the minor
leagues and he said this kid can hit you
know you're thinking a 300 hitter the
problem is Danny they teach hitting
differently and it and it bothers me I'm
with you I I hated striking out I don't
care if I popped up to the pitcher but
when you struck out that pitcher got you
and I and I always tell you this you
know hitting is is a mentality you have
to figure out and believe that you're
the greatest player in the world from
the on Deck Circle walking to that home
plate you know facing Roger Clemens
think about it undrafted guy like myself
LA City General College Lamar University
to the northern league and now I've got
a 7 time saw a Young Award winner on the
mound that six foot five and he's God I
have you have to create an attitude
hitting and to me it's a grind they have
so much information they're so
information based and their spin rate
and the degrees of the curveball and
they have these machines that are five
hundred thousand dollars in the
clubhouse that you can go in there and
track the starting pitcher that day
basically coming out of that wind up and
seeing the degrees it's too much in my
opinion I think Kevin Long's one of the
greatest hitting coaches in baseball
he's the heading coach for the
Philadelphia Phillies but I think what
they're asking schwarber to do is hit
homers hit homers and do your thing so I
think they're okay with the strikeouts
nobody's a perfect player nobody's the
speed power combination you get paid 300
to 500 million dollars these days
schwarber does exactly what he's paid to
do and that's the hit home runs drive
and runs set the tone and let me tell
you as the leadoff hitter it is a unique
scene but because of the walks and the
on base percentage do you care if he's
singling do you care if he's got 48
singles and 55 home runs if he's got
over 300 you know 340 on base so he does
a little bit of everything other than
the average
when do you start to get nervous if
you're an angels fan with shoheheotani
yeah it's probably now I mean obviously
the article comes out when he cleaned
out his locker at the end of the season
he had the surgery uh what a unique
player what a unicorn we've never seen
this Danny we've heard about Babe Ruth
but what he was able to do healthy you
know he throws 100 miles an hour with a
split banner and he hits 45 to 50 home
runs and he runs better than you think
he's a six foot four if not five guy and
he's such a sweet guy there's
intangibles there and then the marketing
aspect of it so sometimes the numbers
don't make sense to guys like you and I
I mean I know you're rich now because
you stopped playing baseball you went to
basketball and turned into Dan Patrick
God bless you my point being is that
shohei Otani it'll be a unique contract
people ask me all the time what did that
cost him I wouldn't even know where to
start because if you're paying guys 350
million dollars as a position player and
you got Aces like Garrett Cole that are
at 300 million well is that number start
with a six now it might start with a
four you still get them in June next
year the offensive type scene like Bryce
Harper who da you know Dash replacement
for first base and you wait for that
Tommy John to come back you will have
him back well where is he going to play
he'll play in San Francisco he'll play
with the Dodgers he'll play for the Red
Sox the Yankees the big boys in my
opinion I think there's a sleeper team
the Giants and they got sneaky money you
know uh we'll see what what happens uh
but you know you're only going to limit
yourself to five teams that can afford
that you know because they they took a
run at Aaron judge and Carlos Correa uh
thankfully they missed out on Korea but
uh I thought they had a real shot with
judge so maybe maybe they do spend that
money to get him in there in San
Francisco
um I know you lost uh teammate uh Tim
Wakefield passing away and uh
if you want to you know give the
audience just your thoughts on that then
I have a question about the knuckleball
pitcher yeah I'll tell you this right
now and I know uh this is this was hard
I I was boarding a plane in Los Angeles
was visiting my uncle Cal who's you know
having a rough time with cancer
ironically I get on a plane Sunday
morning was called by the Red Sox Miss
Pam and she told me to hear the news as
I was boarding and she said we lost him
and the reason why I like this white
ghost went over my face I couldn't
believe it Stacy Wakefield his wife a
remarkable Bostonian toughest Nails one
of my favorite wives I've ever played
with she was diagnosed with pancreatic
cancer a year ago she's battling for her
life Tim Wakefield and I played in the
Tahoe event he's healthy he's a golfer
he's us he's a wonderful human being he
treated everybody kind always wanted to
do right came up as a position player
with the Pirates you know and then
learned the knuckleball and turned into
the most unbelievable uh knuckleball
pitcher this game seen for many years
but it was devastating came in with a
headache about a month ago uh got an MRI
had cancer brain tumor they two days
later they had the surgery and then he
had to wait a month to start chemo was
starting this week and Sunday had a
seizure they rushed into the hospital he
didn't make it and I'll tell you
you know it's a it's a tough situation
man because as you know you know your
work whether it's a team business you
your family and we celebrate a
championship the first one in 86 years
he I was very close to Tim and his wife
and his kids Brianna who's a senior in
high school and I think about her
battling his son Trevor he's autistic uh
19 year old boy but Brianna sitting here
as a senior in high school mom gets
diagnosed with pancreatic cancer
battling and then Dad randomly in a
month span passes devastating news
brutal for the family of baseball brutal
for personally and just keep your
prayers high and high and higher as high
as you can go for this family Danny
because this was a great man that we
lost at way too young at age and 57
years old
it's a tough segue after something that
was put so beautifully I I did want to
ask you about how you can prepare for
the knuckleball do they have pitching
machines when we were in uh Scottsdale
the Giants spring training site uh you
know Gabe kapler said that they could
recreate the uh curveball that Kershaw
has like the pitching machine can can
these pitching machines recreate a
knuckleball
no and I I I loved it at first base we'd
play the Yankees and you'd see Posada
and these guys they're changing their
stances they're open they're La they're
low listen I didn't get a chance to face
Tim till I went to the Orioles so I
played with him for three years with the
Red Sox I heard all the lingo at first
base guys are just going crazy I took it
as a way as this the old saying right is
if it's High Let It Fly if it's low Let
It Go the amazing part about a
knuckleball is that you got to take it
for fun you got to get in your softball
stance you got a leg kick straight up
and I try to hit a home run every time I
just there's no other way you can't stay
inside the baseball you can't sit here
and try to work your swing because what
happens is that one pitch it starts out
like the old Bugs Bunny it just stays
and then it drops off the table right
before home plate to the outside corner
it might stay and Rise if it catches the
right win and kind of finish above your
belt buckle it might stay flat the one
thing about Tim wakefield's knuckleball
is he could control this thing he would
throw between 58 and 68 he can throw a
little harder with two strikes it's the
most amazing pitch in baseball it's you
know you're spacing 95 to 100 I always
thought it was like a day off regardless
if you're gonna dribble it you're gonna
look funny you're gonna pop up but if
you got one that didn't move it was like
a batting practice pitch that you threw
in high school Danny good to visit with
you as always and thank you for the
words uh 10 week Wakefield your former
teammate um appreciate you thank you
buddy
thank you Kevin Millar you can see him
on intentional talk on MLB all post
season long air is pre and post game
coverage throughout October